las expresiones cuadráticas 4x cuadrada
+ 12 x + 9 y 4x cuadrada menos 9 tienen
un factor binomial en común que factor
binomial comparten ok como siempre te
invito a que hagas una pausa y trates de
resolver este problema tú solo
ok hagamos esto al factorizar estas dos
expresiones verdad y tratemos de ver si
tienen un binomio en común así que vamos
a comenzar con esta expresión que
tenemos aquí 4x cuadrada más 12 x más 9
y lo que podemos observar es lo
siguiente aquí tenemos una expresión al
cuadrado verdad esto simplemente será 2x
al cuadrado verdad y por otro lado
tenemos este 9 que lo podemos ver
simplemente como 3 al cuadrado muy bien
entonces tendríamos 2x elevado al
cuadrado verdad eso corresponde a esto
que tenemos aquí y también tenemos 3 al
cuadrado que es 9 verdad entonces uno
podría intentar ver si es que esta
expresión cumple el patrón que ya hemos
distinguido para los trinomios cuadrados
perfectos verdad entonces nos
preguntamos si este término de aquí
satisface ese patrón verdad es decir
tendríamos que ver que 12 se puede ver
como el doble
este 2 por este 3 y si pensamos un
poquito más a detalle podemos ver que el
doble de este 2 por este 3 sería 2 por 2
por 3 2 por 2 son 4 por 3 son 2 de
verdad entonces en efecto satisface ese
patrón verdad es decir satisface el
doble de este 2 que tenemos aquí por 2
por este 3 verdad por 3 y finalmente
multiplicamos por nuestra letra x verdad
y esto por supuesto lo estamos sumando
entonces en realidad esto es un trinomio
cuadrado perfecto verdad y si esto no te
suena conocido te invito a que revises
los los vídeos de khan academy que hemos
desarrollado de este tema muy bien
entonces lo que podemos hacer ahora es
lo siguiente verdad esto que tenemos
aquí será igual verdad a esta expresión
elevado al cuadrado ya que es un
trinomio cuadrado perfecto es en
realidad se puede factorizar como un
vino
elevado al cuadrado y de hecho el
binomio que va aquí sería 2x verdad más
3 elevado al cuadrado muy bien entonces
2 x 3 elevado al cuadrado sería el
cuadrado de este que es 2 x al cuadrado
el cuadrado de este otro número que es 3
3 elevado al cuadrado y luego el doble
producto de 2x por 3 verdad el doble por
producto de 2x por 3 muy bien por
supuesto esto también lo podríamos
reescribir simplemente como 2 x + 3 x 2
x 3 cierto sería multiplicar este
binomio consigo mismo
12 veces verdad nada más ahora bien
vamos a tomar la siguiente expresión que
sería 4x cuadrada menos 9 muy bien
entonces tenemos 4x cuadrada menos 9 y
lo que podemos observar de esta
expresión es que es una diferencia de
cuadrados verdad 4x cuadrada en realidad
es
2x elevado al cuadrado cierto y además
tenemos este 9 que lo podemos ver como 3
al cuadrado entonces tenemos una
diferencia de cuadrados y eso sabemos
factorizar lo muy bien verdad nuevamente
si esto no te suena conocido te invito a
que revises los vídeos de khan academy
en este tema de hecho la forma en la que
podemos factorizar esta diferencia de
cuadrados es como un binomio verdad
donde aquí tenemos un más y aquí tenemos
un menos verdad son binomios conjugados
verdad y ya sabemos que aquí va 2x aquí
también irá 2x y en el siguiente término
irá tres y menos tres muy bien entonces
aquí ya tenemos factorizar a la
expresión 4x cuadrada menos 9 y ahora lo
único que tenemos que hacer es ver si
coinciden si tienen algún factor
binomial en común y podemos ver
claramente que este de aquí
exactamente el mismo que tenemos acá muy
bien entonces estos dos coinciden y es
el binomio que comparten verdad 2 x 3 es
un factor binomial en común